I love you back bro uh thank you so much
for such an unbelievable welcome
actually we've been talking backstage
and I guess I'm gonna actually see how
you guys react to this I as I've been
kind of prepping for this talk following
the hashtag following the momentum over
the last couple weeks and now with such
a warm welcome I feel like I'd be doing
a disservice if I kind of spent you know
the 73% of this talk on stuff that
you've seen on YouTube or have seen me
before do so I'm of the mindset of
possibly going into a complete hour of
qat but I can also give a talk why don't
we do this way how many people would
like to start lining up and go into QA
see where that takes us and then I'll do
a talk on the back end if if that's not
the right direction let show hands and
how many people want the talk [ __ ] it
feels very 50/50
that's totally [ __ ] backfired [ __ ] all
right why don't we do this why don't why
don't why don't we do this why don't I
start riffing a little bit why don't you
why don't the people that want to ask
questions actually line up and start
getting behind the behind the mics and
maybe I'll create some [ __ ] weird
Toronto hybrid a [ __ ] talk and QA and
take it from there so all right so let
me start talking about some of the stuff
that's interesting to me right now
I think that one thing that everybody in
this room should be pondering and one
thing that I'm becoming extremely
fascinated by is that we I'm fascinated
by the fact that really I'll be able to
do this for the rest of my life and I'll
be able to continue to build businesses
that are successful and yet it's just
basically the same [ __ ] over and over
which is which is if you go and dissect
what I'm about to talk about for an hour
now and go watch a 2009 talk it's
basically the same exact strategy the
only difference is is that I've put in
the time in the effort to understand the
contextual differences of the places
that were actually paying attention to
so if that was
was about how I built wine library in
the beginning back in 2001 I would still
be talking about the one thing that I
think connects all of us which is I
don't care what you do here or what your
ambition is to solve the world's
problems to start a business to whatever
it may be
b2b business a b2c business a product a
service the number one thing we all
battle for and the number one North Star
that everybody in this room should
understand is it's all about attention
attention is the asset once you have the
attention then what you say what you do
what you put out the creative is the
variable of you being massively
successful or nobody giving a [ __ ] right
and so the thing that I've been doing is
very simply not being romantic about
where the attention is I would have
loved for it to have stayed on Twitter
forever
I moved first I moved best I was one of
the 20 most follow people on it and had
the world frozen in 2011 and stayed
still and that played out I would have
been in a very nice spot I didn't want
to put in the hours from 1:00 to 4:00 in
the morning figuring out Socialcam and
Vine which then gave me the strategies
and the abilities to be good at snapchat
and Instagram video but I always know
that it is completely irrelevant
everything I've done up to this moment
if I want to be successful and if I want
to be in a place where I'm blessed with
the fact that people want to come and
see me talk so you know really it's
quite scary to me well I'm thrilled to
layer on top of it but the punchline and
literally I could say this and leave
because it's the only thing I believe in
which is you need to understand where
the attention is the better your product
or services the more successful you're
gonna be because I promise you one thing
there's no marketing strategy or tactic
that I'm gonna be able to tell you that
if your product is [ __ ] it's not going
to work right so it's better if your
thing is good your wine store your book
your sneaker your SAS product it's
better if your thing is good however the
punchline of everything I believe in and
the things that have given me
opportunities to be successful is where
is the attention right now that is
priced and that's a very important
variable TV and outdoor and billboards
and Google AdWords and all this stuff
they still work they just don't work as
well for the time and financial
allocation as the moment when they were
in their prime Facebook works
ridiculously well right now if you're an
actual practitioner of it and in thirty
six months
it won't work as well because it will be
more expensive to achieve the same exact
result as you do today I'm not spending
time on musically right now for any
other reason then if it actually pops
and goes mainstream and ages above eight
to twelve year olds and becomes a
platform because don't forget just five
minutes ago Facebook was only for
college kids if it does that I want to
have the land grab the hundred thousand
followers I already have on a platform
that's only eight to twelve year old
girls you know will turn into nothing
for me other than maybe go to [ __ ]
jail you know you know is is gonna turn
into nothing for me unless it ages up
but what it does I'm there and I win my
game is quite simple I want to buy up
beachfront property and build the best
buildings and restaurants and homes and
as long as I'm right one out of three
times
the ROI was positive for all the work it
blows my mind how many of you in
marketing and business drew a line in
the sand and did not want to start a
snapchat account
earlier this year because you were
scared the amount of time and effort
would that you would put into it
wouldn't have a result for you when you
have to realize that's the only thing
you should be doing rinse and repeat
rinse and repeat on every platform until
you have your moment of your arbitrage
I've had four to five significant
moments of this day trading attention it
started in 1996 by actually even having
a website as I look around here there's
a lot of youngsters in the crowd but for
a couple of us that were around back
then
in nineteen ninety four or five six
people debated if the internet was a fad
the way we debate a new app being a fad
the whole [ __ ] thing my dad got made
fun of by all his friends that we didn't
open a second
liquor store instead we built a website
right that was the first being right
about underpriced attention because
$15,000 to build a website is a hell of
a lot less than a million dollars to
build a liquor store and that website
generated 40 million dollars in sales in
no way would have that liquor store done
that that was the right rub I did that
in tactics by other moves including
email how many people in this audience
have done email marketing in their
career raise your hands Wow awesome that
was awesome um this is gonna be even
more awesome in 1997 I had two hundred
thousand people on an email newsletter
that had 91.3% open rates don't clap for
me I'm no hero it was just a timing
thing it was because all of you [ __ ]
hadn't started email marketing yet right
so so now that same email is bigger it's
been around for a decade and two decades
and yet it's got 31.7%
open rates right I mean the open race is
one thing I think it had at one point
like 59% click in the email to Add to
Cart it was unbelievable we built the
business on it then Google AdWords came
along right I literally think god I
wasn't making videos back then I was
like this Google thing is stupid why
don't they have ads on the home page you
know but when Google AdWords started
I bought the word wine for five cents a
clip because back then the minimum was
five cents not ten cents a click and I
owned it for nine and a half months
before anybody bid me up
that was the arbitrage now that same
term wine is a four dollar and thirty
seven cent word right it's it's no
different it's but there's millions of
stories of me doing that where it didn't
work out hence Socialcam or if you're
hardcore web 2.0 how many of you
remember Clark the thing that was the
next Twitter but it went this way
instead of this was [ __ ] crazy anyway
and so basically my core moves were a
website an email newsletter a Google ad
campaign and then for a lot of you you
may know this my career took
biggest turn when three months after
came out there was something called
YouTube I looked at it I'm like I think
this is gonna be big and within the year
of YouTube being in existence before any
one video had ever hit 1 million views I
started a 20 minute wine show called
Wine Library TV and it worked it was the
first time that content was driving
sales for me weirdly enough on a show
where I was panning my own wines and it
really changed the course of my career
in many ways because it drugged me more
into the web 2.0 world YouTube sold for
2 billion dollars I got freaked out by
that I said this talent could do more
for me so I decided to invest in the
next things that I believed in in order
those three things were Twitter Facebook
and Tumblr that was good and and and and
that's how we got here right it was very
good and so and so I might be able to
buy the Jets good and and so
and so and so that I guess what I'm
trying to figure out and what's the
biggest legacy I can leave from
tonight's talk is a couple of pillars of
there are tried-and-true things that
will happen for him for example what am
I most fearful of I'm fearful that this
room has a lot of fake entrepreneurs
that are running companies that when the
global economy slows down and they can't
raise money that they'll go out of
business because they're not actually
building a business they're building a
product and really just a financial
arbitrage machine and all their behavior
is predicated on appeasing VCS who won't
be there for you when you get to the
next step right thanks for Clara so that
I'm worried about and I'm worried about
a lot of different things the supply and
demand of everybody doing the same thing
right there's a million things I'm
worried about or what are dangerous
things for all of us in this room what
am I most in control of emotion control
of talking to you guys about
self-awareness and like what actually
allows you to win I know that one of the
only things I do well because it's just
true only one of the only things I do
better than the market is I am intuitive
of what people are gonna do slightly
ahead and fast enough and it's really
always backed by data I love when people
like you were so early on snapchat
yeah after it spent a year on the top of
the App Store right
it's just that I'm willing to put in the
work that so few others are because I
view it as the cost of entry not a risk
move and I'm stunned by how many people
could go to a conference like this know
who I am
and the other speakers are and continue
to poopoo innovation changes because
it's not convenient to your work ethic
or how you're making money when you have
the audacity to want to live the life
that you actually want to live in this
room and to me that's the punchline like
in a world where in the world where
there's no [ __ ] way you're here
tonight in this room and you don't have
massive ambition and you are seeing the
world in a different way than the masses
don't go get caught up in our bubble you
are seeing the world in a different way
than 99% of people I just don't
understand when you're asking for the
fruits at this high of a level why so
many of you are not put
in the work I have startup Starman
investor in right now that have three
months worth of money left have no money
coming their way whatsoever the product
is [ __ ] they're out of business in three
months and they went to [ __ ]
Coachella and so that to me is what's a
very fascinating thing that I want to
like figure out through QA or this talk
or [ __ ] email me I don't know but we
are living through a remarkable time
where business people are people that
people want to take selfies with the
entrepreneur has never been more put on
a pedestal and this [ __ ] is gonna crash
down it's just what always happens and
to me I feel a massive sense of
responsibility as a human being as
somebody who's benefited from it to
really talk about it because there's a
lot of [ __ ] we're not talking about in
our world
I have acquaintances thank you I mean
not to go debbie downer and I'll get out
of this very quickly but I want to get
this off my chest
I have acquaintances that are in deep
depression and if you're paying
attention in the tech business world
there's people that are committing
suicide because their businesses are not
successful and yet our entire world is
saying anybody can do it it's so easy
celebrating when people raise money
Congrats
you gave away a piece of your business
cuz you weren't good enough to make
money [ __ ] Congrats like we have
totally totally allowed the VC community
to paint a certain narrative and because
it is now easier to go and start a
company and raise money instead of going
getting a job and by the way I don't
blame one youngster should I a go and
work at a job at an entry-level in the
current ecosystem of the world and be
treated like [ __ ] and not make a lot of
money or should I be go raise a bunch of
money and do my own thing and be my own
boss and seem cool and if it fails
there's really fundamentally no
repercussion and I learned and so we're
in this very interesting
I'm and so what I want to do in this
room today is start having a far more
interesting debate of do you want to win
because let me promise you something
being number eighteen at Instagram made
you a lot more money than being number
one at insta [ __ ] and I think there's a
lot of people in this room who are not
putting themselves in a position to
succeed because they either lack
self-awareness or be are just blindly
following the narrative of the current
ecosystem and I want to suffocate the
conversation to see if we can provide
more value to our ecosystem because
there are so many things that we are not
talking about I am thrilled through Q&A
to give you the detailed ways to make
Instagram stories provide you more
upside if you sell homemade jam thrilled
to do it but I'm also impassive like
what's going right how many James funny
and so but i but i equally want to
challenge this hour that we have
together to like level up the
conversation because for again and i'm
watching some of the people that have
been around the block a couple times
like i have this is a foregone
conclusion this is ninety three percent
of the people in this room are working
at TD Bank and Rogers in eighteen months
and so there's a way to not do that that
way is called to become quite practical
that way is called actually build a
[ __ ] business that way is called know
what you're good at and surround
yourself with the other things so that
you can do the other two things I just
mentioned the problem is that [ __ ] is
not a sexy to talk about I'm here to
[ __ ] talk about it
that felt good let's mix it up what's
your name yes your honor
hey Ashley awesome louder louder
no worries can you guys make this louder
to her now no good
it's almost slammed into at the
tradeshow no worries funny because you
were so busy on snapchat yeah I get it
it's great so my question to you is I'm
starting a YouTube channel actually okay
just putting content yes so what is the
best piece of advice for me who's
actually starting to give a [ __ ] about
YouTube so when you say give a [ __ ]
let's define that first so I'm putting
the time in relevant content and what
would you like the content to do have
people sign up for your gym which is
great that you're running a business I'm
just a book by your book okay so here's
the advice I would give you so is the
book alive and real got it I would put
out I would take the first strategy
would be to do everything you can to not
get people to buy the book
the second you make the shift and think
that you're not selling the book but
that you're building a media company
that provides people value around what
you wrote about you will have a
fundamental difference it is stunning to
me how many more books I sell than most
people by spending as much time as
possible of giving away the book for
free like there's no reason to buy any
of my books as a lot of you know if
you've decided to watch everything I've
said for a year for free so it's a time
saver if you decide to go that route but
it is stunning Ashley clinically ash yes
great ash it is it is stunning how many
people here bought my book at a sheer
guilt and wanting to give back to what I
gave them
how many people here buy my ship because
of that
and so I think if you're thinking you're
doing a YouTube channel and producing
content cuz you want to sell the book
you're gonna be selling and that's the
quickest way to not sell something and
so I would just provide unbelievable
content force them to not need that book
and that's how I would go about the
content amount of people here that hold
back the thing that they're trying to
sell that they don't realize that if
they gave away that holdback thing they
would sell a lot more the other thing I
would do is I would do a lot of Facebook
video and run target ads against it
YouTube's a great channel it's
unbelievable it's highly competitive and
very difficult for discovery and has
takes a lot of time to build momentum
unless you're doing jv's with other
youtube stars whereas in a facebook
environment you can get very narrowed by
spending 50 and $100 in ads to amplify
the video that you made so I would not
in 2017 have a YouTube only strategy
with Facebook yeah yep okay okay by not
spending any time trying to convince
them so let's break this down and again
if I'm gonna do QA
I'm gonna mix here between trying to
give advice to all of you and then
bouncing back to giving advice so the
reason I answered that is that across
this whole room standpoint the amount of
time many of you are spending trying to
convince somebody who's not sellable to
buy your thing is destroying your
top-line growth
I have always sold [ __ ] that nobody
believed in whether it was new regions
of wine whether it was social media
whether it was me I've always sold
things that nobody believed in and by
spending zero time spending one second
to audit if they believed in it and once
recognizing that they didn't moving on
it has allowed me to be far more
successful now specifically for you
there's a second layer question if
there's only 80 people in the world that
could buy it you don't have that many
more to go to so depending on how many
people you can sell to if you can sell
to everybody or to a lot of people you
should spend zero seconds trying to
convince somebody who is unsellable and
keep trying to find the next person that
is sellable that's why both the
businesses that I've run have grown in
top-line revenue very quickly it's a
very very rare thing on for some reason
but it brings enormous value if you have
80 people or a hundred 50 people then
you have to go and reverse and go deep
as [ __ ] be patient as hell and chip away
on a human level because people buy from
people but convincing any money on
something that is subjective cuz it's
subjective bro like you being the best
at service is subjective no [ __ ] you
think you are but I don't know if that's
worth more to me than what I've got in
place and you know this nobody likes
change if they have legacy
infrastructure the pain of change is
always scaring entrepreneurs people are
scared to change that's where all the
money is and so that would be my answer
yeah what's that yeah I mean for the
people that follow my stuff I secretly
probably weirdly don't want them to win
because I want to buy them and win it's
just a better story for the Disney film
are you hitting on me bro respect hey
Garry Daniel hey Daniel so I train
salespeople I have about 300 from
relationship yep yes and I got ideas
coming to me all the time Daniel we
should do this Danny we should do that
yep we're gonna increase by doing this
apply this so I guess my question is is
how do I build that core group of people
I actually listen to to apply those
principles to move our business forward
because I got 300 you know questions
coming my way of how we should do things
how would you build your core group and
who would you listen to I don't listen
to anybody and I'm being dead serious
but I equally listen to everybody and so
I know that's an interesting
contradiction but the truth is you're
asking me how to make a decision but in
its raw
raus form and the truth is your success
needs to be predicated on how you make
decisions like my whole life is taking
in data at scale and then how I
synthesize how many people here work in
Big Data raise your hands so for the few
of you like I'm so fascinated by big
data right it's such a buzzword
everybody so but it's big data's not the
punchline what you do with the data is
the punchline right so like how you
synthesize or interpret it is the
punchline of big data I don't know bro I
sure don't Michael Jordan sucked on the
Wizards that was good I like that
I've never used that one before I
[ __ ] hate Michael Jordan too so
that's perfect
no man I would tell you that I would
tell you that my biggest flaw and I and
I don't think of this as a cool thing I
don't think my lack of mentors or my
leaning on others is cool I don't I just
know it's me and I'm unable to break me
I just don't want to listen to anybody
else I just don't and and I swear on my
life I do not think that that makes me
great or awesome I genuinely believe
it's a flaw and I think that there's a
lot of things that I learn at 45 and 52
and 57 that I literally could learn
tomorrow over a drink it just I don't
want to thank you bro hey man hi
I'm fascinated by your film short
documentary document not create yes and
I love imitating you
okay right everybody you look at Beyonce
today you look at Barack Obama today
you don't look at how much work they've
put in their game you can tell me I
worked smart I don't work hard I can
tell you something [ __ ]
I work smart and hard too so I started
this project called what would you do
what would you do if you're not afraid
what would you do with what if you're
not afraid yeah 30 days challenge
documenting myself based on your you
know connecting to what you yep created
what would you do if you're not afraid
I'm asking you the question yes and then
if you like it I would love to challenge
everybody here instead of just going
become lazy to for 30 days document what
they are doing and we created
documentary in about all of the good
stories that were being created and I
love you so much Gary I love you burger
so what's the question the question is
what would you do as garyvee today today
if you're not afraid you know it's
interesting I I I'm gonna tell you
something this is a very I can't believe
I'm gonna go there so I I got really
lucky
I'm stunningly unafraid in my lane right
like one of the things that I implore so
many of you to really debate why I
preach self-awareness and I don't speak
to how to find it because I don't think
I know I think you need to talk about
the [ __ ] you know here's what I know
it's [ __ ] important right how you get
there I don't know I think there's a lot
of hard wiring I think there's a lot of
parenting issues I think there's a lot
of other people that can tackle that
issue but the reason I almost feel like
I never I'm like living life completely
unafraid is it's I won't go out of my
comfort zone my lane in business and
this like if this was 40 million people
I'm so cozy cuz I'm talking about my
[ __ ] if they gave me a piece of paper to
read to you right now I would [ __ ] my
[ __ ] pants because I can't read like
like I'm being dead serious with you
like I'm like uh you know like I mean
it's not that bad but it's pretty
[ __ ] bad um when I think about like
like I've genuinely thought about this
based on this question I've been having
this weird idea for the last two or
three years to actually go out in public
naked I think it's the scariest thing
no no I'm not doing it but bro bro
that's the easy part so I don't know I
don't look I don't know how to answer it
but here's what I can tell you I think I
think that I think it's actually more
interesting to have a conversation of
how do you put yourself in a position
that you're actually never afraid that
if you close your world and you believe
in what you believe and you stay to the
[ __ ] you know like what then starts to
happen because what starts to happen at
least from somebody who I think has been
really executing this for a little while
now you start getting confidence
completely cuz you're just there you
know I don't and more importantly way
too many of us something happened to me
three or four years ago I started
getting very quiet in environments where
I didn't know what the [ __ ] I was
talking about so when I go out with
friends I think we all there's something
I still to this day and I'm almost done
with it it's almost fully out of me
you know what I think about how many
times somebody said to you like hey you
know this right and you're like uh-huh
and you have no [ __ ] idea I do that
all the time ten years ago and I've been
chipping away at it and it's been
liberating and unbelievable and I will
tell you that when I go out with friends
or couples with my wife and we talk
about health care or politics or sign I
get real quiet like me could go through
a whole dinner being like ridiculously
quiet which is [ __ ] insane and I
would tell you start becoming more black
and white about get deeper and better in
the [ __ ] that you know and what comes
natural to you and get real quiet don't
feel a need to have your two [ __ ]
cents on every [ __ ] thing in the
world so are we starting the documentary
challenge to ask those people to
document whether you're working on for
30 days and I will I think you asked
that's on them so guys I'm asking you no
hesitation and we're gonna make an
amazing kick-ass documentary about it
for 30 days but don't but don't do it
unless he sits the rest of this talk
without a shirt on
so I should stay the rest of the talk
without shirt yes in a seat though you
need to get out of the mic you've taken
up too much time my name is Richard my
daughter 17 she's going to a meeting
tonight with my wife yes to discuss with
her school her University options what
she wants to do she's incredibly
courageous marketing mind communications
mind I'm taping you right now and I'd
like you to talk to her like she was
your 17 year old daughter in terms of
how she should consider her university
career how she should maximize that
experience to prepare her for the world
that you see she may be entering into so
her name is Chiara Chiara I have no idea
what's about to happen but it's about to
get interesting Chiara here's what I
would say Chiara I would tell you that
there is not a school on earth not a
university or college that exists that
isn't even remotely equipped to educate
you properly on communications and
marketing in the world we live in today
so I have no interest Cara to get your
mom and dad mad at me but I would tell
you that here would be my four year
strategy I would go to university
especially as she going here in Canada
she's she's talking about NYU she's
talking about San Fran is she collecting
debt or you guys paying for it I think
she's just enamored by big brands but is
she gonna pay for college so she's not
collecting debt alright Kiera you're
gonna have to have a weird conversation
with your mom and dad because the first
thing I'm passionate about is for you to
not have any debt because if you're
gonna go to a business that is gonna
sell you a [ __ ] product that you are
then going to pay compounded interest in
that you can't even declare bankruptcy
to get out of that's called extortion
[ __ ] up [ __ ] crazy ass [ __ ]
but but Kira if that number is not that
high and you can get some other things
that drives down that cost the second
move would be to take your last
four-year ocation of your life hook up a
whole bunch have or or not a you know
depending on your own radar here that
maybe one dude seven that's on you don't
let them judge I'm sure she is
and if you want to learn about marketing
and communications spend a lot of time
online and consume relevant 2017 content
from people that are actually doing it
not professors that are so not practical
and so romantic of how it used to be
that I've traveled the best universities
in the world and have literally thrown
up all over myself while I've been
prepped to talk listening to the
horseshit that those professors are
shoving down these kids throats you're
welcome brother love you
all right let's calm it down there's a
[ __ ] naked dude happy ok and my
question is around calls to action okay
so calls to action for you of the
organization's or for when people land
on those people's websites like from a
UI UX standpoint for me for example when
I understood I'm not against that and I
think we all you know a lot of this is
macro and micro conversation for example
a lot of you know that I don't ask for
anything and then every two or three
years when a book is on sale I get very
write hooky and I'm asking hardcore and
I'm basically asking for you to like not
pay your mortgage and use it to buy the
book right so what's really been
interesting in doing that now three
times is I forgot and even it's you know
it's funny I almost kind of want to
forget because it's so disheartening I
spent two years just really giving and
then I start selling in a three month
period but I forget that somebody might
have just got into my ecosystem and I
haven't had the chance to provide that
upfront value look this is a business
you know the a lot of people and how
many people here are familiar with Jab
Jab Jab right hook cool so when I wrote
Jab Jab Jab right hook a lot of people
thought that I wrote it for the people
that didn't understand to give give give
and then ask right people thought that I
was pushing the jab because everybody
was asking the ironic thing
I wrote that book for the people that
didn't know how to ask I had so many
friends that were providing value and
they would like hit me up they're like
I'm doing everything right I'm like
except you didn't ask for any business
so I would say that there's a lot of
ways to do it I would say you should ask
for the call to action but I also think
that you should be strategic about the
call to action for example when you can
put in your copy a link to a landing
page that does it for you instead of use
yelling it over and over at the end of
the video
you're an essence asking for it I would
be very strategic about what your social
media profiles are linking out to I'm
always changing that if you if you know
again a lot of you know this I say this
to you don't listen to what I'm saying
pay attention to what I'm doing there's
a reason I'm changing the URL in my
Twitter and especially my Instagram
because the attention is there over and
over and over and literally if you want
to know what I most give a [ __ ] about
it's the URL that's there right now
whether that's a piece of content or
whether that's the book or my search
engine or whatever it may be a wine
that's what I care about at that moment
and so I would give a lot of thought to
what you don't have to do that the
technical infrastructure allows to do
for you got it
yeah you got it things are awesome bro I
know you you actually have your question
written on your phone I own paper I know
you should sell that on eBay
it's like rare you mean the other day in
the new and because the Friday before
that I don't know if he told you I was
actually kicked out of your office and
so I want to thank you for having that
interview yep but I was wondering at the
end of every podcast I do I asked his
question okay what's your definition of
empowerment and can I come take a selfie
with you on stage you can so you can do
that now
I think empowerment you know I haven't
really thought about my definition of
empowerment I think one isn't be careful
don't die I think I think how are you
you're a piece of work
you're a piece of work get out of here
yes we can do one without him I think I
think I think one is empowered when they
are at complete peace with their
decision making
it is stunning to me how not scared I am
about anything I do nothing I because I
think that when you're intent if you are
able to push your intent to a pretty
pure place and let me explain what I
mean by this
I'm not [ __ ] some Sherpa mother
Theresa type character here here's
here's what I think I am I think I
believe in I think I believe in you know
meritocracy and the game and if you're
better than me I'm pumped for you see I
think the problem is so many people want
to win at somebody else's expense
without understanding that there's so
many variations of winning and every one
of us has a totally different definition
for it and so from me this has been so
easy this journey because my intent is
pure I want to build the biggest [ __ ]
building in town I want to win number
one most money most impact best best
looking you know whatever all that but I
want to do it by actually doing it I
want to build the biggest building by
building the biggest building I see way
too many people wanting to build the
biggest building by tearing everybody
else's buildings down and so I filled
empowered because I feel like it comes
from a good place and I don't question
myself I don't ever worry about it I
know what I'm doing I'm doing it for a
good reason I'm human I'll make mistakes
I'll own the [ __ ] out of those mistakes
if I make them vaynermedia every one of
its problems my fault you want the
riches that comes along with it you
better take the [ __ ] that comes along
with it and so I think it's intent when
you've got your intent in the right
place I think you're empowered my man
you got it my man good to see you I just
want to thank you publicly for fitting
in on my birthday in February 26
I requested on Twitter 26 seconds of
your time and your team made it happen
that was awesome but I wanted to ask you
this question it was too cold outside
that day and you're on your way to a
game so I run a creative studio creative
agency and I know that you have I think
it's 600 plus person agency now
obviously three or four locations
Mike was 705 705 all right you gotta
keep updating the BIOS and I get it go
ahead so my question is you never really
talked about how you how you would go
from like you know two or three people
five people to 500 it's a huge it's a
dramatic shift what what would be like
your key hires or your key strategies
from there's so many solopreneurs here
individual yes what's the gap between
the one I think I think the biggest
difference between me and a lot of my
friends when I audit what they're doing
is too many of you that have your own
business
watch [ __ ] too soon too many of you take
money off the table
I built my dad's business from a three
to a sixty million dollar business but
quicker I built it from 3 to 30 in three
years I was 25 years old a lot of my
friends went to good schools got good
jobs made a hundred thousand a year got
an BMW and I was paying myself $47,000 a
year and living in a [ __ ] apartment
because I was investing it to build a
foundation too many people in this room
want to build a business but are taking
too big of a salary or taking profits
interests to buy a [ __ ] watch
maybe you can go on one vacation not for
Rick and so and so I think I think
there's several differences I think I'm
dramatically more talented than
everybody in this room and selling so
that helps me grow faster I think I give
a [ __ ] way more about people than most
people in this room which allows me to
have continuity of team and care about
HR so for me the way I built my
company's our HR and sales and not
taking money off the table to buy dumb
[ __ ] cool pretty much that was nice
meeting you know I love you so much I
love you so much cool who's next what's
up man tremendous plug and let's clap it
up for the hustle straight up I have
four friends that have died from drug
overdoses story brought me to tears yep
I ran out and give them a hug and first
off I want to thank Giovanni for
bringing you and the rest of these
amazing speakers
so my question is looking to open up a
ranch for at-risk teens okay I do
everything from spending full days with
kids that have attempted to commit
suicide
I work with a gang exiting program in
the Jane and Finch region and they need
a permanent facility yes I found a
facility it's 2.6 million I could
probably buy it for two million I need
to do a 1 million dollar raise okay from
social media your professional opinion
what's the best and most effective way
to do that well I mean look a lot of the
Kickstarter platforms are out there
right you make the video you get the
emotional play you get the right one or
two funders it creates virality the
problem is that's a 1 to 3 percent
chance right but I still think you
should do that I think you you know you
can definitely get somebody to create
I'm sure there's three people that were
raised for him now to do the video work
on that project and away you go there
you go did you do a no [ __ ] shirt of
course anyway
clothes off here's what I would say I
would say you should do the following I
think you should do enormous amounts of
homework on the people with Dan's
profile the tens of thousands of people
that can associate to that story and I
think that you should make a video and I
think you should email it to them and I
think you should do that to 10,000
people and it should be specific to them
which would mean that it will take you
the entire year I guarantee you'll raise
the million dollars versus what
everybody else does which is hope that
somehow it works out look to do it by
not spending an entire year and putting
in the work and so I think you should go
home
map the 10,000 most likely people to
give you between 5,000 and 1 million
literally the ninth person you ask that
is a high net worth individual that
connects with your story may give you
the million in one shot but I think
you've got to do the unscalable go read
the profiles go look at the hundred
thousand richest people in Canada or the
world Google search it out all the way
through figure out the 15 hundred people
that most map
send them a very direct contextual to
them the amount of people that spam me
without any context no romance they just
watch it for me right happens to all
those kind of people every day so you've
got to give them something different you
need to be thoughtful about the headline
that you email with don't do cliche [ __ ]
I get 900 emails a week that say I'm
gonna help you buy the Jets that's an
automatic delete right so you need to be
clever and smart and that's how you'll
raise it and you'll raise it within one
year if you do it that way money in the
bank and bro then bro yo and I'm in for
50k
let's move it hey Gary my name is Jamal
no wonder Oprah does that [ __ ] that's
not good my name is Jamal Jamal my
question is about how giving people
their time back is really powerful and
important yes and I read an article you
wrote about how virtual reality is gonna
be the next big thing in the next maybe
five to seven years such as like the
iPhone or the Internet and so my
question is which industry do you think
is gonna utilize virtual reality the
most in terms of saving time and what
are you looking for as an investor in a
virtual reality business so I'm not sure
you know just like I believe that the
internet was gonna be the platform that
we lived our lives I definitely believe
that something like VR is where we're
gonna live our lives I think in that
article I talked about five to seven
years before we saw the beginning stages
and the article was more predicated on
it's coming but way too many people
think it's coming now there's a lot of
people investing in VR and think in 24
months we're all gonna be walking around
with headsets it's not happening we're
just so far away from be human behavior
on that level but over 10 15 20 years if
we're in contact lenses I mean things
change very quickly you know online
dating 10 years ago was the most taboo
weird [ __ ] ever now 98% of this room is
swiping to the right right so so so I
would say left you're pretty you're
tough [ __ ] so so I would say that I
don't know because when I knew the
internet was gonna be a big deal I
didn't know it was gonna be limo
services hotels and bookstores that were
gonna be addressed first I don't know
but I know that I'll be looking out for
it
I think the thing to think about is not
so much which companies to invest in but
where the opportunity is like what do we
do now that requires us to leave our
apartment that we VR may be better than
our cell or the internet whether that's
shopping because we can see the product
on us with
I don't know what it is but I promise
you this for the people in here that
haven't started thinking about the VR
process your parents and grandparents
thought the internet was a fad they
thought it would be the weirdest thing
ever that you met somebody on a computer
and decided to marry them right they
would think it's insane that you buy a
tomato through a computer device if I
told you that in 1985 so there's a lot
of changed answers I don't know how to
answer that question other than I will
tell you this
you're young as [ __ ] right if you
believe in this you should get very
educated go to every Meetup read every
article don't jump to conclusions don't
be impatient like all your
contemporaries learn make relationships
if you want to make money in VR you can
make it how old are you 22 19 dude
you weren't alive when I launched
winelibrary.com and I need you to
understand that you have so much time if
you were just patient for the next 19
years of your life and built the
foundation to make the money on VR you
would still be 2 years younger than me
right now so I promise you don't try to
figure out something that hasn't been
figured out react to what it is figured
out and used the leverage you created in
this next seven years to be able to be
in a position to react in a fruitful
manner
what's up my man yes thanks my question
is what is your biggest challenge right
now and how can that's very sweet I
first and foremost another flaw of mine
is I have no interest in anybody helping
me do anything it's a very immigrant
kind of like it's like the most disliked
I almost punched you in the face for
that question like it's so weird it's so
weird that that's so like it's it's
visceral to me um I think my biggest
challenge is it's weird right
so I I think my biggest challenge is I'm
like a fat kid with cake right
like I big eyes I think I can do
everything right have so much energy I
have so many ideas and wants and I'm so
attracted to doing 947 thousand things
at once I've proven to myself multiple
times that that's how I lose on a micro
level I don't know man this you know as
you can tell like I'm sure I have tons
of challenges I think the punchline is
I'm just not sure what they are it's way
deeper than you think unwind that one I
I don't I know I have a lot of them I
just don't think it's smart to spend so
much time on them which then makes me
feel like I don't have any
um I think so
like I'm like you that's thank you so
much for the question but I'm like I
don't know we all challenges like I
don't know like my ankle hurts I believe
like but do you know what I mean like
like I think my friends I think dwelling
is a disease
I think complaining is a disease like if
I can't even allow myself with the
gratitude that is running through my
body to articulate to an audience that's
actually spending their time paying
attention to me that I have some
challenge whatever challenge I have I
made that [ __ ] bed and I'm gonna
sleep in it I'm cruising that's the
[ __ ] that's the easiest part of all
time the business side is the only thing
that that back to me is [ __ ] Ford do
you know what a foregone [ __ ]
conclusion is yeah that's fine thank you
cool thank you
hey man my name's Sam
yes respect what I love most about you
is besides the motivation hoorah you've
such actual advice it's like one and
this feeds into my question about a
month ago a switch flicked in my head
like wow I got to be helping people on a
regular basis to bill that leverage and
that comes from you just keep
continuously pounding Howard a 51/49
5149 here's my question uh I graduated
working at a startup I'm a developer
okay one two years old yep I don't know
which muscle to flex should I be in my
room working on product and coding all
day all night should I be spending some
of the time cultivating maintaining
relationships for someone for a
technical person in technology what
would your advice be both okay
oh no like thank you
real pleasure both like cut up the dumb
[ __ ] you know I mean like pokemons go
what the [ __ ]
hey hi my name is Julie Bowie and I
actually dream of a world where everyone
wakes up and simply says thank you yes
so I got a lot of [ __ ] work to do
Jules so I'm working with the guys who
were doing the gratitude app because I
think that's amazing top ok book my
question for you is if you were to start
a blog today yes this environment yes
bless you how would you decide it what
tools do you use it's the same thing
remember when I said early on the speech
that like basically if you saw my speech
from 10 years ago would be the same
thing it would just be different things
ten years ago I would say to you okay so
you've got to make it on blogger you
know I like blogger you know if there's
a community there and then what you do
is you get an RSS feed and really push
to that call to action and I would hit
up other bloggers to guest blog because
that will bring you awareness to the
done today that answer is the same it's
just slightly different ironically it's
the same guy that built it medium to me
is probably the place where I would blog
because it's the one place where you can
get virality even if you don't have an
audience then you need to produce
content that is a gateway drug to your
articles on all your social channels so
you need to build up Twitter and
Facebook and Pinterest and all those
platforms so they become gateways to
your blog then you have to email people
that are writing content in your sphere
and ask them to guest blog so that you
provide them value by giving them good
content and they provide you value by
them giving you exposure to their
audience then you reach out to Forbes
and The Observer and all these different
media sites and say this is what you do
and would they like any free articles
exposure so many people are visceral to
spec work
when you have no leverage spec work is
your best friend right so you need to
provide value in your content that's
what you have right and what you need is
attention so you need to go to anybody
that has attention and figure out what's
the best thing that they can do somebody
got mad at me the other day for asking
for some spec work can anybody give me
some aerial footage in Chicago for our
blog and he's like why don't you [ __ ]
pay for it you can afford it I go I can
or I can do something for somebody that
I do my whole life I still do events
just for the branding and the exposure
when I had a big business and I wanted
to get into tech I emailed Roberts Leo
Laporte and Jake ooh the app that was
competing with Twitter they had a
meet-up in San Francisco and I said can
I come and pour wine at your event so I
made it yet I had nothing but loads of
humility knowing I didn't mean [ __ ] in
tech and I was going to go fly and I
[ __ ] was the help to make
relationships way too many people are
[ __ ] fancy and think they're special
what you need to do is you need to put
in the work to get exposure can I extend
it a little bit or we so like I'm
rolling you've got to cut it
we got my can I go like ten minutes cool
all right Thank You Kimberly but if you
want to rub my ankle go ahead
so I own I own a massage therapy clinic
where's Brandon Brandon's right here he
introduced me to you absorb your content
hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on
that's your son that's Brandon that's my
son you look [ __ ] great
I might say to Gary you look fantastic I
guess and you look like awesome okay
keep going so my my question is I've
always wanted to take what I do in the
wellness field of Massage Therapy and
bring it into the workplace where okay
we'll spend their time smart I find it's
in my experience is very difficult for
people to find time to come totally
super smart so embedded within
organization like I mean I'm very into
this b2b model so keep going hey so what
I want to be able to do is to put my our
business what we do into the workplace
super smart next how I want to know
female I feel an email TD Bank corporate
all of them all of them yes turn away
start and I want your computer
everywhere I'm not joking right Brennan
I need you to push this through as well
email every single business in Canada
that can afford it
tell them what you do and wait for the
people that say yes to say yes and then
go do it and but do I do that and I want
this to be eventually you know before
you franchise and become [ __ ] Tim
Hortons okay but here's we do ready do a
second one well do a first one the
amount of entrepreneurs that are worried
about [ __ ] that's gonna happen in 2024
you don't how many how many clients how
many companies right now have this
embedded in their company from you
that's a zero zero let's worry about
actually said it out loud I'm fired up
about that
here's what I would say one of the
things that has really worked for me is
you need to understand where it's going
long term but you need to address what's
in front of you let's get the first
client before we worry about the Calgary
and Edmonton market absolutely now go hi
Brandon anybody in your office actually
named Rick because I feel bad for Rick
yeah therapy yes there's nobody in my
office named Rick for a lot of you that
don't know me I just used this imaginal
character named Rick as like the guy
that just does everything against
everything I believe in like like you
know but I believe in yellow pages
[ __ ] you Rick you know she should really
worry about expansion globally
you're wrong Rick you know that kind of
[ __ ] just the anti me
I [ __ ] hate Rick yes Brendon we drove
14 hours here to see it can we get a
selfie yes awesome let's move it I love
that where Wow super close to Edison I
love it yeah what would you have told
your 19 year old 19 year old self if he
was in the room right now to hook up
with more chicks and and if you're
looking for employee number 706 I missed
an internship fair to be here right now
so I'm open ready hold on one second
did you just ask for internship yeah you
got it hey we're just giving away [ __ ]
tonight
all right Gary by the way I'm dead
serious are you gonna do it in May when
you're done are you ready now just email
me Gary of vaynermedia cool all right
Gary my name is Tuan come on
I represent a bunch of conscious
business dad's awesome and basically
it's about leadership okay you know and
I do you believe first of all that great
awesome fatherhood is linked to awesome
leadership 100% what's your one is more
than is better than zero that you do
every day to make yourself a better
father that's a great question so so the
one is greater than zero the way you ask
the questions interesting because the
punchline of that I want to make sure
we're gonna save wavelength is I'm just
stunned how many it's actually back to
that last great question of I just think
people are fancy like people want to do
all this stuff and there are willing to
put in the work for a little gain today
and they end up doing nothing because
they just they just don't do it and so
like anything is greater back to that
lovely lady that and Brandon that just
came up like like if they email 400
people and one says yes that's better
than zero clients like you got to put in
a lot of work to get it very little in
the beginning because you have no
leverage and then you build on it as far
as the father thing you know it's
interesting I'm I'm very I'm very I'm in
a very funny spot with my kids because
my kids I so I really am very
disrespectful of my children right so
meaning I think they're gonna be soft
because they're rich right and so a lot
of what I'm thinking about right now and
what a lot of what I do with my children
is I'm trying to honor being parented
the way that I was meaning I think that
I was perfectly parented like my parents
[ __ ] crushed it and so what my
parents did was I was an immigrant right
and I how many people are immigrants or
children of immigrants so
education right pushed so hard so cliche
and my parents saw where my mom saw that
I wasn't that I was something else and
she and she allowed me to do that and
I've had such happiness because of that
and if she boxed me in I wouldn't have
so the thing that I'm allowing my
children to do is I watch my children
every day and I over exaggerate the
things that I think they naturally love
and are great at I want to give them
permission if my dog I don't want so
many my entrepreneur friends are like
you might have kids to be entrepreneurs
I'm like not necessarily I want my kids
to love whatever they do the way I love
being an entrepreneur and if that means
my daughter wants to be the greatest
painter using Tomatoes fine and so what
what the thing that I'm trying to do
every single day is pay attention to who
they actually are so that I can then
reverse engineer them versus what the
majority of my friends are doing which
is mold them into what they want them to
be fantastic
can I have a hug yes Gary what's up
things are phenomenal awesome my name is
Colin what's your name Colin Colin real
pleasure yeah I have a tactical question
great let's do love I love the
askgaryvee show I love how you give such
in-depth answers yes and I think that's
a skill everybody could have if you're
in the boardroom job interview yes press
conference what is what are the
components of a kick-ass answer that's a
great question so you're asking me what
make the component components of a great
answer yes knowing the answer
I'm being dead [ __ ] serious one of
the things that I love about switching
to a lot of QA it hasn't happened here
yet and it doesn't happen a lot because
people usually don't go there with me
but somebody asks something about a
Stephen Hawkins thing at that event that
we were at nonetheless my favorite thing
to do in this environment is to just
answer the question I don't know
and literally move on and it's really
interesting because the crowd loves it
because it just made every other answer
real and I'm so comfortable in my place
now of saying I don't know if somebody
wants super technically deep around the
functionality of something on github
that I wouldn't know the answer to I
would know something maybe be dangerous
but I don't know in detail I think the
reason the askgaryvee show works well is
I either know it very detailed the dirt
or I really understand it in the clouds
theoretically and I'm able to answer
those questions I don't know the
questions before we do the show and you
see how it goes so I think the component
is knowing the answer and I think that's
why so many of us especially the
youngsters in this room and I surely did
it we grossly underestimate experience
like it blows my mind how much better I
am today than the 25 year old version of
me even though I thought that guy was
the most unstoppable force of business
nature ever created I just do and so I
think that the knowing the answer that's
why the show's working because they're
good answers and my audience like that
my buddy who said you keep pounding into
me the 90 wrote like 50 149 like I'm
gonna suffocate the seven or eight
principles that I believe in on you for
as long as you pay attention to me and I
will never change I'm gonna bore the
living [ __ ] out of you because there's
only so many things that actually work
they're just not that attractive
especially right now when everybody
thinks it's so easy
one more one more
yeah one more perfect you and you okay
all right good so here I want to be
respectful sino Giovanni's trying to
wrap it up so let me keep it quick
I've been following you for a long time
thank you there's one thing that I know
about you it's that you're a [ __ ]
competitor and I want to challenge you
right now so there's a game that me my
friends play it's called odds it takes
ten seconds for you to explain five
seconds for us to play but if I win I
want a one-on-one meeting with you for
an hour I'll fly down to New York just
to do it so let me get this straight you
and your comedian friends made up a
[ __ ] game absolutely that you
understand every variable with him it's
the easiest game it's a guessing game
okay you want to play
who gets to who gets to be the judge in
the jury of the answer part of me who's
the judge in the jury of the answer
beauty beauty we have some judges but
you're not gonna need judges good okay
cool so how it works is you went on a
count of three I'm gonna go three two
one and you and I are gonna say a number
between one and ten okay if I get your
number
yep then you and I sit down for a 60
minute meeting in New York on your
schedule done are you into it so you're
gonna go one two three and I'm gonna say
number three two one and then we're
gonna get it done you know hold on
you're gonna go three two one and then
you're gonna say a number between one
and ten that's it okay everybody got it
all right three two one sign [ __ ]
yeah everyone Gary Vaynerchuk Gary
you're my ghost mentor